- On this episode, we talk about Amy.
- Oh, God.
(laughing)
(upbeat funky music)
- Hey everybody, this is Gary Vaynerchuk.
And this is episode 292
of the Ask Gary Vee Show,
on a Friday night, in early Fall.
I'm personally salty as
fuck, the Jets had just lost
to the Cleveland Brown's, I landed at 2:30
in the morning from Cleveland.
Big shout out to the Cleveland
Brown fans, super classy.
Probably helped that
every other one of them
knew who I was.
(laughing)
And I took the first
selfies ever with mean face
in my life, fans rolling up on me,
after the game, asking for selfies.
And I didn't have any smiles
in my body at that point.
So, super salty, energy may be off.
- Jeff specifically says
don't bring that up.
And now you got that out the
way, so we're good to go.
- Yeah, dude, Jeff is super smart.
(laughing)
He's exactly right.
I'm really upset actually, like genuinely.
I've come to realize
the Jets are my Bizarro,
alternative universe version of myself.
It's where I'm pessimist, I
literally, AJ will co-sign this
because AJ never like,
he likes to razz me,
he doesn't like to be like, "Yeah."
He doesn't like, support,
he likes to like, call out.
I literally on the way
to walking to stadium,
I'm like, bro, I had this weird dream
that the Jets are gonna be up 20 to 7
and then Baker's gonna come in,
and they're gonna win
21-20, and it was 14-nothing
instead of 20-7 but literally,
it fucking happened.
Literally the only thing
that I did not want to happen
in this NFL season happened,
Baker took a shit on my face.
- It was a good game
though, very good game.
- No, it wasn't a good game, bro.
(laughing)
It wasn't a good game.
It was a good game--
- I was at--
- Yeah, I'm sure people were entertained.
I'm glad like, America got
to see young quarterbacks
that they think are gonna
be the future of the league.
It's very nice for
everybody except for me.
- Sorry.
- Well, listen,
you guys have both talked so
you might as well introduce
yourself, why don't you
tell the Vayner Nation
who you are, we're gonna
get to the calls today
because I think you guys are
young entrepreneurs, artists,
I'm inspired by you guys
so much so that I went
into business with you, I
tend to never wanna do shit
like this where like, I mix my real life
with the content of my show but
I felt that it was important
because I thought that you
guys represent something
to me which is, there's a
young hustle, social-media
arbitrage, understanding the culture,
knowing what the fuck's
going on, like, guy, and gal,
out there today, that
98% of them are fakers
and will be weeded out, and
it's very rare for me to find
the real in the bullshit,
and you got a little bit
your bullshit, you know,
you guys have a little.
(laughing)
You especially.
He's good.
- Hey!
(laughing)
- You still got like,
meaning--
- Why, the chains?
(laughing)
- Meaning, and I'm obviously
making a joke but meaning
like, it's such a special,
interesting time, in
entrepreneurship, right?
It's such a special time, it's
been put on a cool factor.
The fact that cool people
follow me and think it's cool.
- Yeah.
- That makes crazy,
you were too young to know this.
All of you fuckers, it's crazy.
It'd be literally like
me telling you like,
"Yo, you'll never believe
this, in 20 years,
"construction workers
are gonna be as popular
"as fucking rappers."
- Wow.
- That is literally,
literally what I'm telling you
it would've sounded like if
29 years ago I said to you,
entrepreneurs will be as
cool as athletes and rappers.
Literally, so, very special time.
But you guys have executed so, say hello.
- I'm Mark, Mark Brazil, and me and Jeff
own a company called
IKONICK, I do the business,
Jeff does the art.
- Yeah, I'm the digital artist
and I do half of the business.
- Because of you actually.
- Yeah, because of you
I turned into--
- So, when it started, Gary,
I was on an island by myself
doing all of the business.
And literally--
- And he was the artist?
- And you literally--
- So you were two guys--
- I was emotional, I was
like, stereo-typical artist.
- Yeah, he's got no emotion now.
- So, I did for you what I did for D-Rock.
Systematically broke you
down from your bullshit
and ideology to being more practical.
- Yeah.
- Jeff gives valuable
business advice now, now like--
- And that freaks you out a little bit.
- I love it.
(laughing)
The more the merrier, I mean, it's just.
I mean, and--
- Tell your origin story.
This was comic book number one.
- Comic book number one.
- Like, what did you guys,
like, your girlfriends were dating
and you met begrudgingly.
- Oh.
You're kind of close.
- Kind of close.
- Really?
(laughing)
- Kind of close, close.
(laughing loudly)
(applauding)
- I'm up right now, bud.
Fuck, I'm pumped.
- And what--
- See, I told you guys were cliche.
(laughing)
Go ahead.
- Eight years ago, at an NYU dorm,
I would wake up at 8:00
AM, next to a girl,
and she tells me, you need
to meet this guy, Jeff Cole.
Who at that time--
(laughing)
I swear to God.
- It was so random.
- For no reason at all,
I had a comic book--
- You guys had a similar hookup
style or what? (laughing)
- Not a lot actually.
(laughing)
I had a comic book T-shirt company
and she connected me with
him, and we, for three years,
I independently contracted
him, and we only talked
over Gmail, we had never even met before.
And we--
- Were you guys both
in New York?
- No, I was in Chicago
at the time.
- I was in New York.
- You went to high school with this girl
or you just did like a--
- No, well, no, I'm sorry,
I was at the University
of Arizona at the time.
- Okay.
- And yeah.
- You knew her?
- I wasn't gonna be doing--
- You just knew this woman.
- Yeah, no,
she went to Arizona with me,
and I didn't even do digital
art yet, I was kind of, I
just majored in illustration
at Arizona.
- And it basically--
- She knew you were a good artist.
- Yeah.
- You guys hook up.
- Yeah, I mean--
- And the wake-up conversation
from the hook up is--
- I swear to God.
- You need to meet Jeff Cole.
- Yeah, it's so ironic.
And literally, we've known each other--
- Do you guys like, let's
talk about this for a minute.
- I wish her a happy birthday
every year on Facebook.
- You've gotta do way
more than that, dick.
(laughing)
What the f?
You wish happy birthday on Facebook
to people you once were
in study hall with.
You do not wish happy
birthday, you need to sell her
a ton, you need to send her a ton of art.
- [Mark] I've already done that, yeah.
- That's a good idea.
- You need to email her,
DM her, or text her, and find
out what she's into in life.
- Yeah.
- You guys need to buy her,
like, you need to do something right.
(laughing)
- Didn't end that well.
- That's fine.
But it's 100 years ago.
- I know.
- You need to man up and
realize it ended up great.
- Yeah, it's funny how things work out
because it literally--
- Bro, it ended up great.
- I'm just saying--
- You may not be together.
- Yeah.
- But you found your business
love.
(laughing)
- Business love.
- Do you guys
consider each other business loves?
- I love him like a brother, yes.
- That's right.
- Yeah.
- You found your business
love, thus it worked out great.
- Yeah.
- And we need to do,
can we make a commitment here today?
Now that I'm part of the company,
can we make a commitment?
What's her first name?
- Amy.
- Can we make a commitment to Amy?
- Amy's gotten a shout out,
she's getting a heavy shout out
right now.
- Listen,
can we make a commitment to
Amy that we have to recognize
the way life actually works,
though it may have not ended up
the way you want it to, or nicely,
in a romantic sense, she created--
- A monster.
- Yeah, I do love her for that. (laughing)
- I mean, but you're not showing it.
- That's true.
- You love her once a year.
- Jeff, you need to step
up, you weren't your heart,
or your relationship wasn't bad.
You need to--
- It wasn't, you're right.
You're right.
- He was in it,
and I have empathy for
that, you on the other hand,
this is actually your fault,
you need to be the one
that needs to step up and
do the right thing by Amy.
- You're right, man, we'll make it up.
- Can you make me a piece of art
that says, do the right thing by Amy?
- Yes, I promise, I'll
add the eleventh piece--
- Literally, I'm gonna
hang it right there.
I'll make it right there,
I didn't even realize
I had that space up there,
right there, let's measure it.
Do the right thing by Amy, I want it.
- [Jeff] We have that on
camera so it's going down.
- Done, it's firm,
alright, we've establish.
Can we, alright, so, origin story.
You wake up, hookup in
college style, you gotta meet
this guy Jeff Cole, weird
conversation for a post-hookup
but, cool, I'll go with it, and so, what?
You're like, cool, I'm
so excited, I can't wait
to reach out to Jeff Cole?
(laughing)
- No, he called me the
next day and I'm like,
who is this random guy?
- Yeah.
- Like, literally, you, I love
that, that's hustler move.
So you call him, you're like--
- I'm aggressive.
- Yo, bro?
- Yeah, for sure.
- Are you Jeff, is this Jeff Cole?
- Yeah, basically.
- And you're like,
this is Brazil.
- Yeah.
- Basically, this is, yeah,
it's pretty accurate, yeah.
- Keep going. (laughing)
- And literally it was,
you know, we worked company on company,
and you know, I was always
the number two or three
at the company, definitely
under-incentivized
and under-utilized, and I
always had Jeff as a designer.
And just, the work ethic, second to known,
his design is, I mean, you see them.
- Yeah, everyone knows it.
- And it came to a point
where we were with these companies,
we weren't really happy, and
about, it's now probably about
16, 17, months ago, we
went from Square Space
to Shopify, and through,
obviously we were bartering
on Instagram, and getting big posts,
making couple thousand
dollars here and there,
but the second we started doing paid ads,
month one, six figures, and
then we just went on a bender.
- Facebook.
So, Facebook and Instagram
is where the company started.
- ICONICK.
- ICONICK, correct.
- Should probably know how to pronounce
in the shit that I invest in.
- Yeah.
- I can pronounce my own store.
- And it literally was--
- Don't worry.
- It was me, Jeff, and
then we were running ads.
And his 16-year-old brother,
we were paying $0.25
to process the orders,
and we were part-time.
- You were paying him $0.25 an order?
- Per order.
- All of us.
I mean, all of us.
- Yeah--
- No, I know, but you were
paying him $0.25 an order
to prep, yeah, no, I get it.
- Also, fired.
- And Jeff was giving him some sneakers.
- Yeah, I gave him some sneakers.
- So we did our first
$2,000,000 in top-line revenue
from 5:00 AM to 8:00 AM,
and then at 5 or 6:00 PM
when our partner in
the other company left,
when that door shut, that was
the best moment of our life.
We'd go and get coffee,
and then we'd be jacked
from 5 or 6:00 til 3:00 in the morning.
And then it got to a point
where we're like, wow,
this is getting serious, and
then that day, we went all in.
And then things just took
it to a whole new level.
- Since we haven't framed it up,
what is the company for
everybody listening?
- ICONICK is affordable art,
starting at $50 to $700.
It's direct to consumer,
the core of the company
kind of has that motivational,
inspirational DNA.
And that kind of drove us to
become a legitimate company.
And now we've iterated
into, you know, with the NBA
licenses.
- Right,
you do licensing and original, right?
- Correct.
- Yeah.
- Mainly original.
- Yeah, it was Jeff
that did all the designs
for the first about, year.
And now we're starting
to bring on more designs.
- Artists that fuck with
you 'cause your Cole account
is so fire on Instagram,
that would DM you,
you'd vet, and you're like, oh shit,
this is how I can scale.
- He makes fun.
My Instagram is like a biz-dev hub.
- Yeah.
- 100%.
D-Rock is how we've, you
know, like, the D-Rock world
is like, whether it's
Babbin or Caleb, like,
we found way better people than D-Rock
by people that were hitting up D-Rock.
(laughing)
- We found, so, when D-Rock
posted Austin, our video guy,
we found our second Austin,
our second video guy through that.
So, basically D-Rock both ours.
- Yeah, D-Rock is
literally like a job board.
(laughing)
Like, when people are like,
"Yo, what's up with,"
you know, a lot of people
call other video people, D-Rock.
Like that has become like a real, right?
Like your guy Shane, like--
- He's our D-Rock.
- Yeah, like that has become a real thing
which is really fucking
amazing in a lot of ways.
But when I hear D-Rock, I'm
like, oh, yeah, that's like
a job board, like that's how
I literally think about it.
Though you haven't been able
to find somebody from our team
like, miraculously, everybody's
finding lots of stuff
yet we can't find another
person for our team.
- We either meet them
through us, so like--
- Yeah.
- It's less possible
and as hard as we do it.
- That's the problem
we have, like, duplicating Jeff, you know.
Finding--
- It is so hard.
- We've tried getting junior designers--
- Right, 'cause when, you
know, to D-Rock's point
and I don't know if you guys heard it
here on the podcast so I'll repeat it.
Finding somebody that
bleeds out of their eyes,
which is a term I use for
just like, worth ethic,
it's hard to find somebody
who is both artistic
and outrageously in a
not only a work ethic
because there's a net hours, right?
Like, an artist could work
18 hours but if her or his
output is a single piece of content,
where our requirement for 18 hours is 837,
that's a big fucking delta.
- Like, for me and my lane,
I want bleed out of their
eyes and intelligence
'cause I can develop that.
- Sure.
- With him, it's skill.
- Talk to me about
when he became a better
business man than you
by mainly just listening to me.
(laughing)
- Better than me?
Well, (laughing) I gotta--
(laughing)
- When did he become a
better businessman than you
on the back of just listening--
- [Jeff] I have some
really good business ideas.
- He does.
- But most of those
are directly coming from me, right?
- Yeah.
- Okay,
I just wanted to make sure. (laughing)
- We've gotten to a point now where we--
- Which means I'm a better
businessman than you.
- Oh!
(laughing)
- I'm just trying to, you
know, we're just trying
to play the game here.
- Right now,
the market says you are,
as per what you would say,
the market says you are, yes.
- But you've got time.
You're young, how old are you?
- I just turned 33 a couple,
a week and a half ago.
- You look good.
- Thank you, bro.
- You look good for 31.
- Thank you.
- There is some gray in the beard though.
- I know.
- Have you found that
to be to your advantage,
distinguished, or?
- Some girls stay up,
I don't believe them,
to be honest with you.
- You think they're pandering
to you.
- I think so.
- But what about the huge
headlines of me and Scooter
being involved, has that helped your?
- Things have changed.
(uproarious laughing)
This interview is going
not where I wanted it to go
right now but.
(laughing)
- Well, here's why.
- Yeah.
- Because I rarely do anything
that I mix business with
on my own platform so I figured
before we get to the calls,
I'm gonna make this interview
nothing like you dreamed
it up, right?
- Oh man.
- You thought like, I'd
set it up, knock it out,
sell some fucking art, get a sale.
(laughing)
Mainly, I'm making sure
that you remember the pain of Amy,
(laughing)
making sure that we talk
about the gray, you know,
like I'm going completely
different places with this--
- It's fine.
- Is that fair?
- No, on a serious note, what's, you know,
here is the reason I said yes.
- Yeah.
- Because you guys fully
fuckin' executed on my core thesis
that I've been trying to
shove down the fuckin' throat
of society, and you guys
know the same way I know
that we're not that special.
- Self-aware,
it's all self-aware.
- It's just, there's a moment
in time right now that
people, for some reason,
and listen, I'm pretty
good at fuckin' like,
forcing my message down people's throats.
There's this inherent
human thing that people
are just not willing to take advantage
of this ludicrous opportunity.
- How, it's ridiculous, like, you say,
Facebook, Instagram influencers
and people aren't doing it.
It blows our mind, like, we
are pushing so hard there
and we're finding other
distribution channels now
where we can get, you
know, cheap traffic but--
- Give me one, just like, give it to them,
don't be scared.
- I was just talking
to Taboola, it's a random one.
- Right, no, I know what it is.
- Yeah, Taboola, so--
- You're happy with that.
- We're happy with that right now.
- Good.
- Like, how we're at right now
how the business is structured,
I look at it as three things.
Everything starts with content,
you could do no-pay traffic,
if you have good content,
you could blow up.
And the other two big things--
- And let's stay here
because this is really
why I wanted you guys,
'cause I wanna bring value to my audience.
You're right, you can blow
up with no paid, no money,
but that will take some time.
- Correct.
- Even the best of content,
it's not like you're,
if you're the fire fire,
if you're the next me,
and you're gonna trump
me, your name's Sally
and you're gonna fuckin' destroy me.
If you just put out your
first video on Instagram
right now, it's gonna take a few minutes.
It's gonna take a fuckin' few minutes.
- If you're authentic
though, you're gonna find
some people that like what you think--
- 100,000%
- And it's one, two, three,
and you just have to, like
you said, be patient--
- Tomorrow, I'm gonna
wake up early as fuck
and I'm gonna go garage-sailing,
and I'm gonna make fire content.
You fuckin' love it,
dude, give me love, dude,
honestly bro, real quick, I'm sorry to--
- I will get up and go with you tomorrow.
(laughing and chatting)
- Dude, dude,
on a serious note, it
really meant a lot to me
that you DM, first of
all, that day was crazy.
I just did this the other day, like,
I really kind of did it, first of all,
it was the most creative I, like, right?
Like, I'm looking at my
team like, I'm more creative
when I do garage-sale content,
like I'm doing a picture,
then a video, and then this,
tomorrow I'm gonna fuckin'
destroy it, tomorrow's
gonna be the greatest story
of all time, I'm gonna
find something crazy.
That NASA jacket was nuts,
went for $82, bought it for $1.
Bought it for a fuckin' $1.
- 82 ask.
(laughing)
- Anyway.
- Yeah, so, content, and then
I think the two big things
is, you know, you call it
attention, we call it traffic.
It's the same thing.
- Yeah, same thing.
- So, you know, now as, you
know, leading the company,
I'm a biz-dev guy so I
just want as much traffic
as possible.
- Awareness.
- And then the last thing,
which people, I really don't
think focus on, is conversion tactics.
- 100%
- How do you convert that?
How do you get one uptick
of your conversion--
- And there's two extremes,
you guys are in the sales
business, you're in retail,
where I come from, right?
You're sellin' art, I sold wine.
So, you're absolutely
right about conversion.
I, and this, I wanna give
everybody the full look.
I'm actually so deep right now into brand
that the reason I go so
deep into non-conversion
is 'cause I wanna be on the other side
of just like, pure brand, right?
Like, if Nike tried to
get you to actually buy
their product in everything they do,
well, they wouldn't be brand.
- Well, I do think that we've
shifted a lot towards a lot more brand.
I don't know if you've seen our account.
- I have.
- But, since we've spoke--
- Yup, I'm aware.
- We took a big, big shift--
- I'm aware.
- Where it's just storytelling
straight storytelling.
- I'm watching, I'm watching.
- Hey, hey, yeah.
- And I'm pumped about it.
- He's got a record on that too.
- And look, look, obviously
we had that combo.
Obviously I'm happy to watch
you do it, I have seen it.
Obviously, the headlines
of me and Scooter investing
in the company was a big
deal and just brought general
awareness, and there's so much more to go.
- Yeah.
- And I think
when you get those two things singing.
- Mm-hmm.
- It gets real scary.
- Yeah.
- Like, when we think about
all the stuff we're
selling, with sneakers,
and different stuff, like,
I got a big wine project
comin' up like, when you
get brand, and selling down,
like if Nike had 5,000
people in a call center,
cold calling, doing
tactical stuff that you,
they would do better.
- Yup.
- Like, I don't think
people, like, you know,
like now, when you start
at trillions and billions,
it's hard to get your juices goin'.
But for like, 99.9% of
the people watching,
and by the way, is it Facebook?
Facebook, if you're watching right now,
put in your phone numbers,
I really wanna go into call
in show, I wanna establish
who these dudes were
but I realize, as you can tell,
I wanted to razz a little and have fun,
just out of family love,
give you a little context
that the only reason here,
listen, I do a lot of investing,
a lot of stuff, why are these dudes here?
They fuckin' listened like, I don't even,
was it Justin Giogrande,
I'm trying to remember who.
- Yeah, Giogrande, yup.
- A guy that works with me,
great guy at Vayner Sports,
one of AJ's right hands,
connected us, I went
in like, not courtesy.
I'm always meeting new
people, it wasn't courtesy,
I'm always fishing but I'm not like,
interested in fish right now.
- I don't think you know
that we, I guess you don't
know the whole back story.
- Probably not, maybe I do.
- We say we Gary'd Gary--
- Love it.
- Because what happens is--
- I believe you, talk about it.
- You guys asked to do
his logo, he did it,
we charge a lot, and I go--
- One more time, we--
- I did the Vayner Sports rebrand.
- You did?
- Yeah.
- Yes.
- I don't know that.
Cool, that's amazing, I
feel way better about it.
- And they go--
- No wonder I like it.
- How much, they go, how much?
And I go, Jeff, we're
not gonna charge 'em.
We're gonna provide value
first and what happened--
- This was Giogrande?
- This was Giogrande.
- Keep goin'.
- And Giogrande,
he's slick, and then six months later,
I email Giogrande, I go,
we're Gary disciples,
here's the last six months of revenue.
Give us 15 minutes with Gary,
and then he screen shotted
the text message he had with you.
And then we got that 15
minutes at Beverly Hills.
And all I need is the in-person.
- I totally get it.
- I knew when we met
in person, game over, explosiveness.
- And it was.
- And then, it happened.
- It was 'cause it was real.
- So, that's the other thing
with us is that I think,
especially living in LA,
is no matter where this
company goes or where we go,
me and Jeff are value-first
with everything.
Like, right now, there is one person
that I think I always
listen to, obviously besides
my family, someone that,
they gifted me something
and I haven't posted it on Instagram.
Everything else, I'm putting out there,
I'm doing for other people,
and I think that's the other
thing that people, you
know, you're talking about
brand over sales, I
think it's value first.
- Couldn't agree more.
- That so many people--
- It's leverage, it's leverage.
- It's you have the leverage everywhere.
- You made a fuckin'
cockamamie and fuckin' logo
that lead to like, all this.
- I did a lot.
- Very true.
- You know what I mean though?
Like, I'm obviously down playing.
(laughing)
But you made a logo and like,
whatever money was there, no
matter how much you charged,
it was disproportionately less, you know,
like, than the value you got in return by.
- 100%.
- And to your point,
like, I've gotten to, where, you know,
you youngsters are gonna love this.
You're gonna get to a
point where you're giving
without actually worrying
about if you're gonna get
to meet up, like, where it gets real fun.
- I think we're starting to get there.
- I believe you.
- Where we don't--
- I believe you, you're just doin' it.
- Yeah.
- It's not like, okay,
one day Kobe's gonna fuckin' sit with me
or I'm gonna get to, and by the way,
that's the right way to think about it
because if you're really good at, listen,
I probably subconsciously still do things
with the thought of like, oh
shit, but I'm gonna fuckin',
you know.
(laughing)
That's gonna how I'm gonna buy the Jets.
But where I got probably a decade ago
but more likely maybe a half a decade ago,
zero expectations, like if
Giogrande said, go fuck yourself.
You would be blown away
by how now, in my life,
it still happens no matter who you are,
there's always other things, right?
- Yeah.
- It doesn't register.
Now, I'm not gonna overly
go crazy for Giogrande
the next time, you see where I'm goin'?
- 100%.
- That's where shit,
giving without expectation
is the ultimate.
- I agree.
- You got questions?
Cool, let's go, let's get some call-ins,
I think some people
are gonna get fired up.
- No Amy questions.
(laughing)
- Dude, I'm about to like, go
deep into this Amy content,
I'm getting excited.
(laughing)
- This is epic.
- Yeah. (laughing)
So while Andy's pullin' up the call,
'cause I'm curious,
'cause I was so impressed
with how much PR, like, that
you could feel the buzz.
- You're gonna love it, ready?
Bartered our PR agent.
- Love it.
(laughing)
I love it, barter is my
favorite frickin' word.
I wanna barter my whole life, who's this?
- Hello?
- Raphael,
it's Gary Vee, you're on the show.
- [Raphael] Hey, Gary,
what's going on, man?
- Things are good, my guy, what
do you have questions with?
- [Raphael] Aw, man, I
was watching you guys
and yeah, I've been grinding
for a little while, man.
I have a physical therapy company,
trying to take it, trying to scale.
And it's just been really hard.
Like, kind of grindin', trying to find
the Robin to my Batman, so to speak.
- When you're looking for Robin
what are you offering Robin,
like, yo, help me build my shit
or are you giving up some of the equity?
- [Raphael] I'm always offering equity
just from the gate, you know?
- Yup.
- [Raphael] But a lot of
times, I don't know what it is
but you know, I'm not sure if the people
don't believe in themselves,
they don't believe
in this vision, it's really kind of hard
to find somebody who's like, okay, yeah,
let's do it, like, from
the door, from the gate.
- I get it, I get it.
- I'm showin' them like,
look, you know, I'm sorry you broke this,
and now I'm here.
- I get it, I get it, tell me
this, how many, what are
you lookin' for Robin to do?
- [Raphael] Honestly, what
I'm looking for Robin to do
is kind of bring to the
table some of the things
that I don't have, you know.
- Like?
- [Raphael] Like I'm not always,
I'm not the most charismatic person
so I'm lookin' for like, a
Robin who can help me with--
(child in background)
My son
is telling me I'm not the
most charismatic person.
(laughing)
- You're killin' it on the fuckin' phone.
I'm like, damn, really, that's
not where I thought you were
goin' 'cause I like
the way you're talkin'.
Keep goin'.
- Yeah, like,
you know, not the most charismatic guy
so I know, yeah, I can see how, you know
someone can move through a
room, kind of help with connect.
Like, I can close a deal, you know.
When I'm at a table, I can
negotiate, I can, you know.
You know I know my numbers,
I'm on top of all this
kind of stuff, you know,
that's kind of my strength.
Not really, you know, the intro, you know?
- Okay, so it's not charismatic,
it's the first move.
Once they're farming, the
hunting is harder for you.
Once it's farming, you've got it.
- There you go.
- Okay, keep goin'.
- So, that--
- Where do you live?
- Of all seasons--
- I live in suburbs of DC,
I live in Maryland.
- Okay, DC, Maryland.
Got it, lookin' for a Robin who she or he
is good at hunting, keep goin'.
And what do you want to
sell them, physical therapy?
- [Raphael] Not just physical therapy
but got some ideas and since, look,
you know, you've got a wide reach,
I don't wanna put all my ideas out there
but I'm trying to kind
of innovate as far as
how the services are delivered.
Of course, you know healthcare, you know,
it's changed, and it's
starting to get really squishy
as far as, you know,
the margins goin' down
but the pay is still high,
so I'm trying to find a way
to change the game as far
as how it's delivered,
the method it's delivered, and so forth.
- Can I say something?
- You can say anything.
- Yeah, I mean, it looks
like you're looking
for a glorified salesperson,
and I think for that,
you know, just going on job boards,
you can probably find
someone, and I think the fact
that you're willing to offer
equity to go with, obviously,
some sort of salary, is
something that not many people
are willing to offer at the gate.
So I think you have a
pretty good offering.
Have you tried just utilizing resources
and looking for a salesperson?
- [Raphael] I have, a lot of
my friends are sales people
but the thing is is that I
have friends that are sales
people, I have other associates
that are sales people,
but one thing I've known, what I notice
about salespeople, they're
not always entrepreneurial.
They're really good at sales
but then really risk-averse.
Then when you have people
who are risk-averse,
it's like, they're out of the game
before you even, you know,
before you even get to the door.
- That's tough.
- I mean,
I'm dealing with a fire right now
'cause I felt like you had it down
but like--
(laughing)
To me, very simply, like--
You like that one?
- I mean,
I feel like he needs to be
going on like, networking events
and just be out there more, like for us,
we're just out there,
and it's a contact sport.
That's how I see it, that's how I see it.
- Okay.
- Yeah, I also think like,
honestly man, like, I caught the tail-end
of the risk-adverse, this and that.
Like, I just would spend
no energy on, you know,
what's wrong or what's
not, or what's tough.
I'm just fascinated.
- Right.
- Like, it's fascinating to
me that catching the tail-end,
and I apologize that I had
to just take care of this,
it's fascinating to me that
I never once in my life
blamed the customer.
- Sure.
- And I don't know, like,
I'm not saying, I'm right,
and you fucked up, like, I
don't even wanna go there.
I'm trying to bring value
for everybody listening.
Holy shit never in my life, we
were reading something today.
We're working on this
cool fucking project.
And in it, the customer wasn't blamed.
Yeah, I did peak at it
but you guys hadn't.
There's this story that I
was listening to by the team.
I don't want to go too much into it
but the bottom line is, net, net.
I was proud of the team,
I didn't touch it at all.
In this story, let's just stick with that,
the customer was not blamed,
and I took note of that,
and I was like, good, they did a good job.
I highly recommend for you of like, forget
about risk-adverse, how
many people have you asked?
If 17 people were risk-adverse
when you approached them
or 1,700, or 17,000, that's still nobody
in the scheme of the game.
- I feel like
that's the answer is it's more people.
- That's it.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
And that, oh, what's that?
- Offense is vital choice.
- Explain, Andy, that sounds smart.
- [Andy] You always go on
offense, and I feel like offense
is something that you can, it's because--
- It's on you.
- Yeah.
- If you keep asking people--
- Whereas like,
defense is one somebody else, right?
Yeah man, listen, finding
Robin, or selling to clients,
this new delivery mechanism that you have,
it's all about just
finding people that say yes
in the beginning,
everything I've ever done,
eCommerce in '96, social
media agency in '09,
these were fucking things
that nobody wanted.
All I got were no's, I found
a couple of fuckin' yeses.
And everybody's out here
trying to fuckin' think that
everything should be a
yes, does that make sense?
- [Raphael] Yeah, perfect sense, perfect.
- Right, so like, I think
just making that mindset
all of a sudden, the way it manifests,
is you're not dwelling on that no,
you're not worried that
you kissed another joker
instead of finding a
Robin, you understand?
- [Raphael] Yes, man, I
needed that, thank you.
- Kissing the Joker?
- That's good,
you like that?
(laughing)
Cool man, well, good luck.
- Okay, so,
look, I can book that, good job.
- Alright, good luck man, thank you.
And that's it, like,
right, sometimes, you know,
it's like, I'm always
fascinated by the macro
versus the micro advice, like usually on
the Ask Gary Vee Show, I
like that I can go micro.
We had to go macro on him.
- That's why there wasn't
really an answer, I think
it's just, it sounds crazy.
- It's a mindset.
- It's just, work harder,
kind of, it's just keep going.
- But working harder,
you know, it's funny,
and I believe in working harder.
But it's work harder with
the right prospective.
- Yeah.
- Like, it's a lot easier
to work 17 hours a day when
you know why you're doing it.
- Yeah.
- That call probably, remind
me of that cold calling video
you did in Wine Library.
- That was the best.
- You would shoot emails
like, how do I monetize my vlog?
- I was so pissed,
that's such an OG video.
I literally Googled--
- It was the first caller
on your site.
(laughing)
- And the guy's like, I'm in.
- You warned me.
(laughing)
- I just think like,
people are like, but the
market's not ready for,
remember with John Legend,
when the guy was like,
yo, people aren't ready for my shit.
Motherfucker, you sure sucks,
stop blaming listeners.
- Yeah.
- Like, when you have
an art piece that doesn't sell as well,
like I used to love when
I would send an email,
write the copy, pick a wine, buy wine,
try to sell the wine, and it didn't sell.
It'd be like, yeah, I suck, instead of,
aw, these people don't know
that Grigio's the shit.
Who is this?
- Our--
- Andrew.
- Andrew?
Andrew, you're on the show.
- You can please call
the office at 231-86--
- Let's try him again.
Or somebody else, you were
about to say something.
- I think the whole entire
thesis is just with every no,
you're getting closer, and
learning, and refining.
Like, for our whole entire thing
is we love the micro-losses
'cause it's just, it's getting us closer.
- 100%.
- To just getting better,
and better, and better,
that's the whole entire point,
I guess--
- The micro loss
for the macro, like, my
whole life's a micro loss
just to buy the Jets and win
six Superbowl's, that's it.
(phone line ringing)
I hope my first game
ever as a Jets owner is at Cleveland.
And go there and take a--
(laughing)
- Cleveland looked good though.
- They're a very good team,
I like where they're at.
- He's good.
- Their defense
is really good, Denzel
Ward's a good player too.
(phone line ringing)
Who's this?
- David.
- David, don't fuck up.
(phone line ringing)
This is your shot, David.
- [Answering Machine] Your call
has been forwarded to an
automated voice messaging system.
919-280-12360 is not available.
At the tone, please record your message.
When you've finished recording,
you may hang up--
- You're leaving a message?
(laughing)
- Or press one
for more options.
(machine beeps)
- David, it's Gary Vee,
listen, life is so fuckin'
interesting, the fact that
I will never call you back
in the history of our life, fascinates me.
That this moment in
time, like who knows why.
Maybe you're in a bad service area,
maybe you went to go take a quick shit.
I don't know why you didn't pick this up
but the fact that you didn't,
which led to this message
that will now create a scenario
that we'll never interact
ever again, blows my face off of like,
how life actually works.
- How long ago
did he ask the question?
- Have a good day.
- Damn.
- Alright, D-Rock,
what's this, this is the
camera that we were using,
you and I, and we're
gonna sell this on eBay,
you're gonna sell this on eBay.
- No, Seth's going to.
- Seth and you
are going to sell this on eBay.
And the plan is, we're
taking this $3 or $4,000,
$2,000, $3,000, what is it?
- $4,000.
- $4,000 camera, you
and I are gonna sign it.
And then we're gonna put it
on eBay and see what happens.
You're gonna tweet it
out, I'm gonna retweet it.
I'm excited about this,
I can sign it anywhere?
I'm so into this, D-Rock,
I'm so pumped by you.
- I thought that was you, Austin.
- This is so cool, alright, alright there,
you're gonna sign it too,
since you're fuckin' famous
and the D-Rock and all, I
think we got our D-Rock.
It's a job board, alright.
(phone line ringing)
What is this?
- Yosef in New Jersey.
- Yosef?
- Yosef.
- Maybe Joseph?
(phone line ringing)
Okay, it's a Y, yeah, okay, makes sense.
- Hello?
- Yosef,
it's Gary Vee and you're
on the Ask Gary Vee Show.
- Hey, how are you?
- We're tremendous,
you watching the show?
- No, I closed it.
- How was it though, before you left
and broke our hearts?
- It was awesome.
- But the customer's always right,
so it must've sucked.
(laughing)
- No, no, no, no, I was
doing a couple of homework's,
that's why.
- Homework?
- [Yoseph] I'm an undergrad, yeah, yeah.
- Wait a minute, you picked homework
on a Friday night over
the Ask Gary Vee Show
Live on fucking Facebook?
- Yeah,
'cause I can watch it
later on, that's why.
- He won, he won, Yosef,
you're off to a good start
brother, what's your
question for the guys or I?
- I'm sorry?
- Do you have a question?
You put your phone number in.
- Aw, yeah.
I was wondering, how do you
keep to yourself motivated
and like, you keep going, like,
I keep watching your videos
and after like, an hour,
I just, there's like,
no more, you know, it just goes away.
- Okay, so you watch a
video, you get pumped as fuck
for an hour but then it goes
away, is what you're saying?
- Yeah.
- Okay, I'll let you guys
answer first on how you guys
personally motivate yourselves.
- Personally, I think
motivation is all tied
to finding something in life
that you're passionate about.
- Yup.
- And it's tied to effort.
So like, for us, we just work 24/7,
we love what we're doing, and
it's gotten to a point now--
- You're motivated by
actually loving the process.
- The process is amazing,
we don't want this to end.
- Ever.
It's weird, people ask us now, you know,
would you sell the company?
We don't even know that answer anymore.
- Right.
- 'Cause we just love it,
every single day is
amazing, so, find something
you're passionate about and
you can put the effort in.
- Cole?
- You know,
I just have insane
ambition, like I wanna be
the best in the world, so it's hard.
It's like, even like, the
announcement with you,
like, everyone's like, wow, is that like,
the best day of your life?
- You're like, no.
It's fuckin' shit, it's like a blip.
- We celebrated maybe for five minutes.
We did a high five and we
went right back to work.
It's, I don't know--
- It's the ambition.
- Yeah.
- For you,
it's the ambition, for you
it's the love of the process.
- The love of the process.
- And then obviously,
there's a lot of things,
I mean, you have ambition,
you love the process, but
your answer is ambition.
- I want to be all time, the greatest, so.
- Yusef, for me, what's
interesting is I'm gonna go
a different angle because
I think it's gonna help
a lot of people that watch my shit.
I'm super humbled, as you can imagine,
that I can be an energy boost.
You know, watching a video of mine,
much better move than
doin' some fuckin' coke,
or drinkin' some fuckin' Red Bull, right?
Like, I'm excited by that, right?
But the reason that
people aren't sustained,
you know, by my content, in the scenario
that you preached, is
because you're using it
as a bandaid instead of
fixing the issue at hand.
Now, a couple things.
I'd like to ask you
this because of the way
you set up this conversation,
you might not be motivated
as fuck right now and maintain it
because you're actually
in a phase of your life
when you're eating some crow
to set up the next thing.
- Can I ask him something?
Have you found your passion yet?
'Cause I feel like once
you find your passion,
it's hard for that
motivation to kind of die.
- [Yosef] All I know, I wanna do something
that helps people but I'm
trying to find either like,
a health field but I'm not sure yet.
Like, I want to decide
like, I'm studying--
- Go ahead.
- No, no, please, go ahead.
- I'm a sophomore
right now in Rutgers and
I'm not sure what major.
All I know I'm like, I wanna
go into the health field
but I'm not sure which specific,
'cause I wanna give back to the people.
Like, I'm American-Egyptian,
I wanna go back to Egypt
and help out over there
'cause the healthcare system
it just sucks over there kind of.
- So, couple things I
think, I'm glad you asked
that question because I
think that led into like,
my entire thesis, my intuition is, look,
if you want to be in the
health field today, in 2018,
unlike being an entrepreneur,
you do have to go to college.
Like, you know, and
maybe I'm under-educated
on the whole field and so I don't know.
But like, intuitively,
like, if you want to go into
a top-doctor, you know, hospital,
it's hard for me to think
like, you're comin' off this.
Like, 18-year-old me would be like,
yo, fuck, college, I'm
not going to med school,
like, yo, hire me dog, I'm pure talent.
- Yeah.
- Like I don't know
if that's played out, like I
don't know if that's a 2019
playing out, maybe 2027,
maybe some entrepreneurs
or some rogue fuckers start a hospital
that's like all about like just evaluating
on some intuition shit, I don't know.
But right now, I feel like
it, actually, your question,
and where I was going, Yosef,
maybe what you're doing
right now is you can't get macro-motivated
'cause you're in the eating-shit phase.
You're gonna check the box at Rutgers
to find the thing, then go to pre-med.
Like you might know that
you're in fuckin' year one
and two of an eight-year
fuckin' window of eating shit
before you get to actually
do the thing you want.
Does that make sense?
- Yeah.
- Like, I was unmotivated
as fuck in high school.
- Same.
- Like, outrageously unmotivated.
All I was doing was going
through that process
to get me to the time, and
where I found my motivation
was on my side hustle, and
that's why I got D's and F's,
'cause I literally was trying
to sell baseball cards,
and study wine, in every minute of my life
that I could get away with it.
If I had a passive teacher
who didn't give a fuck,
like I was 100% studying baseball
cards and wine every class
and I don't mean like,
ha-ha, and Gary was,
I mean, open the fuckin'
baseball card guide,
or the Wine Spectator,
sit in class, and read it.
Hoping my teacher wouldn't say something.
So I think you might just
be in the eating crow era.
Would that make sense?
- Yeah.
- Look, don't yeah me, does
that make sense or like?
- [Yoseph] Yeah, it's makes sense, yeah.
Lots of sense, yeah.
- And are you okay with that?
That becomes the thing, like, I was okay
with giving up, you know
the reason why I shit on
everybody and come so hard is I was okay
with giving up my 20s
and mid 30s to give back
to my parents, I was okay with that.
And everybody else, like so many else
are just like trying to do all
the funnest stuff, and like
have everything, I was okay
with paying 15 years of due.
Sinan, I look at, dude,
you know how much respect
I have for you on this man, you were okay
with commuting from fuckin'
New York, shitty New York,
I assumed, to fuckin' Jersey,
to work at Wine Library
for 10 or 11, 8, $5 an hour,
whatever the fuck it was.
Because you were like,
fuck it, I'm gonna eat shit
for a year and hope
Gary's not full of shit,
and puts me on, you were okay with that.
And cleanin' the, I know
how it is at Wine Library,
I did it too, so like, I
know what dad's up to there.
(laughing)
Like, you know, like?
Like you know, so, I think the question
you have to ask yourself,
if you're so ideological,
that you're gonna go
back to fuckin' Egypt,
and save the fuckin'
healthcare system of Egypt,
well then, guess what?
Eating shit in university
in America for seven years
in your 20s is minor-leagues
to the ambition
coming out of your fuckin' mouth, my guy.
- Gotcha.
- Take every
single class, every single
class in the medical pocket.
And when you find that one thing you like,
then you're gonna
penetrate that one pocket.
- Or, or, take every fucking class
that has nothing to do
with medical and realize
junior year in fuckin' Rutgers
that you're a fuckin' poet.
- That too.
Try everything.
- Nah, for sure I'm not.
(laughing)
- Right.
So, like, listen--
- I can't write it.
- But you see where I'm going with this?
- Yes, like I think the important part,
like the money shot of this
was like, is the ambition
coming out of your mouth something
that you're willing to pay the dues for?
I am so bent out of shape
tired, of fucking hyperbole,
spitting out of people's mouths
of what they're gonna do and
then when they have to go
and put in the thing to get them there,
they fuckin' balk, 'cause
I'll tell you this, Yosef.
This is about the
re-wiring of perspective.
You might float into
happiness and motivation
for the rest of your
life if you understand
on this Friday night, that the
game is having the tolerance
to eat the shit, to get you in position
to do the thing.
- Facts.
- Word.
- What do you think?
Talk with me here, talk with
me, I'm into this one now.
- [Yosef] No, I totally agree with you.
- So then, so how is it processing?
Is it processing like, oh,
fuck, that might be right,
fuck it, I'm gonna like, go all in,
and I'm gonna find pockets
of like, playing 2K,
or going on dates, or like,
I'll just, I'll appease
myself in the two hours I get to myself
outside of this crazy education thing
that I have to check the box
on for the next six years,
'cause I'm gonna go
fuckin' save the Egyptian
fuckin' medical world, or you saying like,
oh, shit, do I wanna change
the Egyptian medical world?
Or both?
- Both, kind of.
Yeah.
- Cool, man.
I mean, I think that's super right.
That's exactly what your
fuckin' 20s is supposed to be.
- Alright.
- You don't have
to fuckin' figure it out
but I think what you need
to think about is, a lot of 20-year-olds
get real ideological, and
like, one thing you may want
to think about is, is it even capable
of fixing the Egyptian medical world?
Because I'll tell ya what
really is scary to me.
When I hear you talk, I've had drinks
with the 46-year-old
version of you, Yosef.
And you know what the 46-year-old version
of you has said to me?
Oh, fuck, I wish that I knew
that there was no chance
of changing the Egyptian medical world.
So, one thing that I would
tell you to do very carefully
is while you're going
through this process,
audit the reality of your playing field
to see if what you're actually saying
is even fuckin' possible.
- That's a big problem.
There's smaller problems
within that problem.
- Correct.
- That's why I would
find a pocket where you
can sell something small
that can contribute--
- I think that's right.
- Towards solving the bigger problem.
- I think that's right, I think, you know,
when you're 20, you're
gonna rule the world, right?
As you should, I love
it, I want everybody to.
But where I'm going with
is, a level of practicality
that doesn't trap you, that you wake.
What people do when they're ideological
is they're faced with something at 31,
we're like, oh, fuck,
all of this is bullshit.
- Facts again.
- Yeah.
- You see where I'm going, Yosef?
- Yeah, yeah, I see you.
- And the reason
this is all easy for me to give you
is it's based on the
one-hour boost of motivation.
The reason it fades is
'cause it's a bandaid,
it's a quick high off
my communication style
that is wonderful, and
I'm very proud of it,
but it's because we haven't
got to the root of the thing
that you're not able to
keep sustained motivation.
You know what I mean?
- Alright.
- And 'cause it's either you're lying
to yourself of like, what's
coming out of your mouth
isn't true in your heart and your brain,
or, something else, and I really think
it's usually like, when I
hear what you had to say,
it's that there's a part
of you, the logical part
of your brain that's quiet,
and a voice that whispers
once in awhile that says,
yeah, that's actually
not that possible, or this and that.
Which is why I think, you
know, Brazil's talking about it
the right way which is
like, instead of boiling
the ocean, why don't you say like,
I'm gonna fuckin' change
the life of 100 Egyptians,
in the town that my
grandparents came from.
Now you're like, fuck,
I can actually do that.
- I'm not trying to curb
your dreams, either.
It's just something you start there,
and then you can build upon that.
- 100%, or, like, look,
I said I was gonna buy
the NY Jets, big fuckin'
dream, it's just that I knew
there was gonna be a bunch of dog shit
for fuckin' half a century to get there.
Like yesterday, you know,
all the tweets come out
when I get salty about a Jets win.
Don't worry, Gary Vee,
you're gonna buy the Jets
in five years, and I'm like, D, oh my god,
I'm like, no, I'm not, not even close.
(laughing)
- 20.
- You know, so I think you
gotta be real with yourself.
Yosef, what do you, synthesize
the last fucking 15 minutes.
- [Yosef] Just be logical with myself,
and just try to find the real thing.
- That's exactly right
and the way to do that,
the way to do that bro, is to taste.
I think you and I gave the right advice.
- Taste.
- Try everything.
- Alright.
- Like, for people
that found it, good, now quadruple down.
For everybody else who's listened to this
and be like, fuck, that's me, go fencing.
Start a pottery class,
say hello to nine people
that you've seen on campus 48 times
but you don't know their name.
- Yosef, I suck at 80% of things in life.
Just so you.
- Yosef, I suck at 99%
(laughing)
of things in life.
I'm being dead serious, my guy.
Yosef, you're definitely
doing this for you, right?
Like, you don't feel
like this was instilled
by like, mom, or aunt, or
sister, or some documentary?
- No, no, no, just me.
- Cool, good.
- Like that answer.
- Good, man.
Now you just gotta listen,
if the rules of your game
are the game that you're playing,
you've gotta follow them, you
can't get out of education
to get in a position to do
what you want in the current
world, so eat it, the same
way that I wanted to be
in the liquor business,
and help my dad's business,
and all the liquor laws,
these fuckers can ship.
When they talk, do you
understand how angry
I get that they can ship art anywhere
and I couldn't ship wine to Pennsylvania,
and Boston, and all these places.
People don't know what I felt, I hated it.
But guess what, I chose to
fuckin' get into my dad's
liquor business so I don't get to cry
that I couldn't ship
wine to all these places.
That's the business I'm
in, you don't get to cry
that you have to do school
for the next seven years,
and you fuckin' hate it, you
wanna save fuckin' Egypt.
- [Mark] He just went to
go save Egypt, he left us.
- Yosef, are you ghost?
- Yeah, yeah, I'm with you.
Yeah, yeah.
- Oh you were just letting
that settle in?
- Yeah.
- And what came out of you
settling that fucking statement?
What came out on the other
side of your thoughts?
- I just had to really think and realize
if it's my real dream or, as you say,
like my wild, my 20s thing--
- Or let me give you
a good one, bro, let's
like, get to the real point.
This is probably ultimately,
now I'm starting to realize
why the fuck I kept you on the phone.
Or, is it a dream that
you subconsciously liked
the way it positioned you amongst others?
- [Yosef] No, every time if
I think about it like that,
I just like, shove it
down because I don't want,
like, no fame, I just wanna
do it just for the people.
- Not the fame, brother, not the fame.
The way that your mom, dad,
sister, person you like,
six homies, your inner 11, fuck fame.
Do you think that maybe
this is your ambition
because you like the
admiration of the inner 11
when they look at you, when
you say you're gonna do this?
- No, I don't think so.
- Good.
That's great.
- That's a big problem.
I really get it.
- That's a huge problem
for a lot of people, and
I'm pumped, that's great.
This is why, you see how
thoughtful these questions are?
Like, I'm listening to
you, like, I believe you.
Like, honestly, I thought
there was a good chance
that that was the answer, I'm not kidding.
But when you answer like,
oh, I actually feel it,
that's good, so like, these are the,
this is the process, this is
the process that everybody
needs to do, thoughtful
questions, real-life questions,
you understand?
- Yeah, yeah, I understand.
- Help me one more time 'cause
I think you're gonna help
a lot of kids out there,
bro, what, one more time,
I know you said it but like,
where are you at right now?
I know I'm milking this but I'm lovin' it
because I think it really will help.
- [Yosef] What, can you
repeat the question, sorry.
- 100%, what's on your
fuckin' mind right now?
- I just wanna get my grades straight,
just focus on that, get
into the best school,
make connections, try to
like do my point in my dream.
- Love it.
- That's it.
- Let me tell you a couple
things you're gonna love.
Don't over, I'm a bigger
believer in serendipity,
then I am on the brand
positioning of these schools.
Let me explain.
Don't burn yourself out
trying to get certain grades
that may not come natural
to you because these
are the four best medical
schools and you're gonna go
to number 17, because let
me promise you one thing.
The way you said it,
you can find the person
that's gonna cure cancer
at school number 17,
just as easily as you
can at school number one.
So when I heard you say
network, a lot of times
people think you gotta go
to school number one and two
but the way the world's transforming,
and the way that schools
value certain data
versus the data that
actually is gonna play out
over the next 30 years,
my recommendation to you
is not to do the bare minimum
but I would be far closer
to do the bare minimum
than I would to strive
to something that's
unachievable from a GPA.
Because you're gonna
fuckin' burn your life out
trying to get a 3.1 instead of a 2.9.
And at the end of the
day, school number 11
in Connecticut is not going
to be the delta you think
to school 21 in Virginia,
do you understand?
- Yeah, I understand.
- Serendipity will trump that
every day.
- 2.1 GPA, great network.
- Yeah, 1.7, man, shit network
but I could do it myself.
(laughing)
Alright, Yosef,
thanks man.
- I'm sorry,
one more question.
- Dude, what the fuck?
(uproarious laughing and griping)
- [Yosef] What's your
next event in New Jersey?
- You had a 16-minute fucking question.
- You just woke up.
- Nah, I want to see you
in person, what's your
next even in New Jersey?
I know like, one--
- I don't think we have one,
right?
- In October
for your wine club.
- Yosef, coming
for the jugular.
- Oh, the wine tasting.
Yeah, but he's under 21,
Yosef, how old are you?
- [Yosef] I'm 20, I'm
going to be 21 in December.
- What's that?
- I'm going
to be 21 in December.
- I'll probably do,
I have a high likelihood
of doing something
in the first weekend in
December, or second weekend
in December at Wine Library, I would argue
that there's a bigger than 50% chance
that I'll do a public event
on the first Saturday.
Or actually, I could see Black Friday,
I could see a Black Friday,
Saturday, Thanksgiving thing.
(humming)
People with trouble,
probably first now, I'll probably
do first week of December
because if I do Thanksgiving weekend,
people can't travel, and
for me to do a Jersey event,
people will travel from
Rhode Island, Delaware, PA.
So, I would argue first
or second week of December
at Wine Library, and that
will be the next thing.
- Alright, awesome.
- Alright man.
- Thanks so much.
- Take care.
- See you soon.
- Goodbye.
- Wow, that was good,
actually felt like he was
very passionate.
- He was very real.
- Yeah.
- Let's sneak one more in
before we let these fuckin'
good lookin' dudes out.
- [D-Rock] There's quite
a lot of good questions.
I'm trying to maybe get one.
- Just pick one.
- Gary?
- Yes?
- You need to start a D and F club.
- Yeah, that's good idea.
- I'm a part of it.
- Yeah, dude, I was--
- I wanna be a memory.
- Do you have your report card like I do?
- Oh, man, mine was five years, 2.1.
I needed to get a certain
grade on my last class
to get the 2.1.
- I had nightmares
that I didn't graduate high school--
- Hello?
- For years, who is this?
- This is Scott.
- Scott, it's Gary Vee.
You're on the Ask Gary Vee Show.
- Let's go.
- What's up, man?
- Life is good, what do
you have, a question for me
and the boys?
- Oh, yeah.
(laughing)
So, I mean,
I've known Jeff since Jeff was like, five.
We grew up in the same neighborhood.
- Okay, before you go any further.
When's the last time you
and Jeff have interacted
via technology or voice?
- Is this?
I know, oh, Scotty.
- Two days ago.
- Oh, okay, so this is like, your homie?
- A day ago?
- Okay,
well, you guys are actual friends.
- What's your question, Scotty?
- Yeah, see, Cole's getting pissed.
(laughing)
- No.
- Well, no.
My questions is--
- This is exciting.
- Is that--
- Wait, Scotty!
Before you go any further,
before you go to question.
- Sure.
- Tell us a great,
under-the-radar Cole story,
like real under-the-radar,
one that you don't even,
not even, you know how you
and your homies have like the
38 stories you keep recycling?
I wanna hear story number
39, something that Cole
hasn't even thought
about in like, 11 years.
Give me some like, fourth
grade, like, shit his pants
during recess shit.
- Aw.
- Be gentle.
- I mean,
be gentle, um, so, I mean, I
don't think many people know
that Jeff has not always
been the hardest worker
in the neighborhood, so Jeff and I,
Jeff was a little bit of a problem-maker--
- Thug, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Maybe, maybe a little bit
when he was younger.
- Yeah, how so?
- I mean--
(laughing)
- Like, Roman candles or like?
- No.
- Yo, what kind of trouble?
- No, I think, I mean--
- What about mischief like
bats to fuckin' mailboxes shit?
- [Scott] No, Jeff wasn't that
bad but like water balloons
at houses and we had like, I'll
call it the year-older kids
who were like a gang in the neighborhood.
And Jeff, I think Jeff was,
when he was a little bit young,
I don't know if he remember but like,
I mean, a couple kids got in trouble
'cause my grandma was staying over--
(laughing)
And she called the cops
on kids throwing water
balloons at our house.
And all the kids had to line
up in front of our house
and say sorry.
(laughing)
- Are you sure that was me, Scotty?
- I hope not.
(laughing)
- I don't think so.
- Then I'm the one,
see, Gary, you're like--
- I know what I'm doing.
I'm the bad guy.
(laughing)
Scotty, this is the end of your career.
- Yo, let's ask another question.
- What's your question, Scotty?
- [Scotty] So, my question is,
is that Jeff and Mark
strategically brought Gary
and Scooter in on this business.
- Yup.
- And their, I mean,
and you guys are obviously
huge and impactful people.
- Yup.
- In larger industries.
How are you two gonna help build ICONICK
into the world's greatest
and largest art brand ever?
- Oh, I'm not.
(laughing)
The answer is, nothing, zero, this is it.
Ask Gary Vee episode, I
mean, never see these two
fuck faces again.
(laughing)
I can't speak for Scooter,
he'll probably do incredible
things, and like, he'll do a lot.
I, nothing, my preference is I never see
these two dudes again,
that's my game plan.
What do you think, Scotty?
- [Scotty] I mean, I know,
and I've met Mark one time
but we've interacted multiple times.
And I know Jeff forever,
and I think it's possible.
(uproarious laughing)
They're just hella
motivated, I don't know man.
I mean, I don't know if
Jeff's ever told you the story
of when we got to meet
up and link up in LA
but it was a good time, I
mean, just our perspective,
what they're doing combined--
- Scotty, where do you live?
- [Scotty] And I've followed Jeff forever.
- Chicago.
- Dude, I wanna be your friend.
I'm gonna fly you in, Andy, get Scotty.
(laughing)
I'm buying you a plane ticket.
You're coming to hang out
at Vayner for the day.
I just need you around telling stories.
(laughing)
- [Scotty] I have more
stories than you can count.
- I feel it, I feel it.
(laughing)
- [Scotty] If you follow
up, I'll follow up.
- I'm gonna follow up.
- I'll make you
the same promise.
- Literally, right now,
Gary@VaynerMedia.com,
email me and be like,
Scotty from Chicago,
it's me, and you know,
I'm ready to come, and
you email me right now,
I'm sure a bunch of people
are about to email me.
(laughing)
Just so everybody knows,
no, this is gonna be really simple.
Everybody who emails me
that's not the actual Scotty,
I will delete you from
our database forever,
and our servers, and I
will probably also save it
and publicly shame you and
make sure that you go deep
into the black web, your
social security number
will be mine within 24 hours.
- Oh God.
- That's a real threat.
- It is.
(laughing)
- For everyone out there.
I just want everyone to know out there
that they better not impersonate me
because I'm taking like,
just like you said,
I mean, your whole thing is
about taking opportunities.
- This is it!
- And Jeff and Mark
love that, you take the
opportunities, you follow up.
- Dude, I cannot wait,
I'm gonna walk through,
you're gonna tell a story, be like, yo,
this one time, Jeff and I, I can't wait.
I'm looking forward to this
Scotty, I'll see you soon.
- Okay.
- Alright, bye.
- Andy, we need a real question.
Fuckin' Scotty, Jeff's best
friend from fourth grade
who like, sold blow pops with each other.
- Scotty finessed in there.
- That's funny.
- Jesus.
- He's a family friend.
- That's nice, he
sounded like a good dude.
- Yeah.
- He is a good guy.
- He's a good guy.
- Good vibes
but we need to like, come
in, we need to end strong.
Not Scotty the fuckin' story teller.
(laughing)
Though that would be a great T-shirt.
- Scotty the story teller.
- I wanna put his face
on that T-shirt, we'll show him after.
(phone line ringing)
- Hello, this is Jacob.
- Jacob, it's Gary Vee,
you're on the Ask Gary Vee show.
- No fucking way.
- Yes,
it's very fuckin' true.
- Oh my God.
And that language comes from you, wow.
I'm right here next to my
iPhone watching you guys.
And I'm like, they're not
gonna call me, it's stupid.
(laughing) That's crazy,
wow, I'm actually talking
to Gary Vee, I don't
even give a shit anymore.
I'm just happy--
(uproarious laughter)
- Now he's gonna jump off his roof, done.
- That's it, nice, what's
the question my guy?
- [Jacob] So, I have a personal question
and then I have like, a simple question.
Not a simple but my micro
question is how would you scale
from, like, 'cause I notice
there's a process from
going from six figures to seven figures.
I haven't even reached my six figures,
versus the losses--
- Have you reached
five figures, tell the truth,
don't like, or I'll hang up.
- Hey, take it easy, no.
- Well, listen,
I don't know, maybe not,
maybe you haven't started yet.
(laughing)
- I have not.
- Right, so, what about four figures?
Tell the truth, it's okay.
- Yes, I have.
- Okay, so we're at four figures.
The question's about six to seven figures.
- Yes.
- Andy's smiling
'cause he knows I wanna destroy you
because I wanna focus on four to five,
but I'm gonna let that
slide 'cause I love you,
keep goin'.
- [Jacob] I guess my question,
I do social-media marketing,
I mean, I do probably nothing
compared to what you do
but I notice that it's like a system
you have to have to get
where you wanna get.
- Okay.
- So, it's just creating
that system is a process it seems like.
Like, really, about like--
- But the system
is remarkably individual, right?
- Yes.
- Like for example,
my system is lots of
humans, I like scaling
through lots of humans,
most people hate that
because it's not very
profitable in comparison.
I like having the gang around, I like it.
I like mentoring people that
later go out into the world
or, like, to me, staying
with me for 40 years,
or going out to the world,
both winning formulas.
So, that's my formula, a lot of people
make $11 billion a year
sitting behind a computer,
don't wanna talk to one fuckin' person.
This is about self-awareness at scale.
There is no system, don't buy
a system, figure yourself out,
and create the system around you.
- Ah, I see.
- You see what I mean?
- I like that, yeah.
- And it's very important
like, everyone's looking
for the fucking anecdote.
Like, people are like
always like, yo, what's
the secret hashtag.
(laughing)
Like, people ask me that kind of shit.
Like, yo, Zucks,
like, you've got the keys
to like fuckin' Facebook.
Like everybody thinks they're, go ahead.
- [Andy] People don't know
that you're posting on YouTube.
- Yeah, Gary, I didn't know that.
- What's that?
- You're a savage,
you post a lot.
- I knew that.
- [Andy] I was like, yo,
I texted Gary one time
that you should post just
a summary video saying,
I host callers.
- It's just you
pushing the button.
- Yeah.
- [Andy] My friends are like,
who writes his own script,
the homie, it's like--
- The copy looks like you
but I was just thinking about
the amount that you post,
I didn't think it was you.
- Yeah, the copy looks good
to me 'cause the grammar's completely--
(laughing)
No, but let's talk
about authenticity,
everyone's laughing right,
'cause nobody wants to talk about it,
like, it's crazy, one
of my great weaknesses
was my utter, I mean,
guys, this is me 20 years
of writing email copy, you
should have seen the first wine.
Like, I'm dying, I have to
figure out if we can somehow
miraculously find it, I can't even imagine
what the fuck these poor wine customers,
in conservative 1996--
- You were drinking
the wine when you're writing the emails.
- Dude, I was writing
them, and I'm telling you,
20 years later, I'm like,
fuckin' Albert Einstein
of grammar compared to
who I was 20 years ago.
Even in time, you've probably, right?
I can even feel myself now
better than I was when we started
like, it's really cool,
a huge weakness of mine
is probably why most
people, people don't think
I do all my own social media
'cause they can't fathom it
but it's true, I think the only thing
that even gives me a leg to stand on
I think is the copy, when I
started writing longer form
Instagram copy, that
probably was the best thing
to ever happen to me because were like,
maybe there's a prayer that it's me.
- That's good advice
too, I took that advice.
- What's that?
- Long-form copy focus
on the caption, big.
- Huge.
- Intuitive too.
- I love that D-Rock
one time. (mumbling)
- He's not here.
- He left.
- D-Rock, get over here!
- [Andy] He took a really, really dope--
- D-Rock was all pumped
because Atwood's here.
- I used to do one-word captions.
Nu-uh.
- I was down for that story,
you take a really dope
photo, really long captions.
- D-Rock, tell the story, Andy's
about to steal your story.
Tell the story about the long cache in.
- [D-Rock] Posting twice,
first one didn't do well.
So I posted a photo I
thought was really cool.
And they're just gonna add that in.
And I don't really follow
what I thought was,
(mumbling)
- Long copy, right?
- Long copy.
(mumbling)
- Okay.
- Must be nice, 2,000 likes.
(laughing)
- No, it's not that,
I put a lot of effort into it too.
- Okay, none the less, go.
- Then, before I hit her,
I'm like fuck it, that copy was so good.
Screenshot it, dropped it
in and put it in the widget.
(unintelligible mumbling)
- Andy, do you know what you do?
You actually lip what people are saying.
You notice that?
(laughing)
Yeah, that's what's up, baby, love you.
- I've never noticed that.
- Where were we?
What are we talking about?
- Marketing.
(laughing)
Something with marketing.
- Six to seven.
- Oh, six to seven,
authenticity, (humming) anecdote, right.
Bro, there is no fuckin' anecdote.
What you need to do is
figure out yourself.
Don't look at me, or at
Cuban, or these guys,
of fuckin', you know, Sarah Blakey
who created Spanks, or
fuckin' Beth Comstock
who was on the show the other day
who's a beast in corporate,
this is so individual.
Now, there's tried and true things.
Being efficient, being passionate.
There's tried and true things but like,
for example, I've been working
out now for four years,
like, look, as much as I
wanna have like, a huge chest,
it's just not genetically there.
Like I have other things that could work.
And it's like, you have
to wrap you head around
that shit, like, you've
gotta figure yourself out.
And like, you know what really
scares the fuck out of me?
Is I push this all the time,
yet as my popularity grows,
more and more people
are trying to be like me
and I'm a fuckin' off the
reservation, unique fuckin'
character, like my way's
ridiculously not mappable
if it's not your way.
- Yeah.
- Right?
- Like, I'm the worst, I
think I'm the worst person
to try to be like, that's probably right.
(laughing)
- But it's also like
the whole copy thing,
it's always just like,
I'm not gonna clone you.
- But that's what I mean.
That's why I'm like,
look, and then, great,
I'm super happy, and you know, it's fine.
Like, I don't take any pride in it.
It's like, I'm not a good
map, like, I think there's
a lot of people that are
a much better map than me.
Who, oh, by the way, most of those people
when I think of 'em, make
a lot more money than me.
Because it's more like, kind
of like, like, I'm doing
all sorts of crazy things,
like, if you fuckers
aren't watching and listening right now,
actually came here and
watched it for a week,
then you'd be like, (laughing)
you'd kind of throw up
your hands and be like, I don't even.
- No, I'm good.
(laughing)
- Right, send it Seth, right?
Seth, what do you think?
(laughing)
- You think he's nuts.
- I think a lot of.
(distant talking)
- Yeah, that's the first thing.
You want to talk about
something way scarier
than I do my own social media?
I am programmed from 7:00am
till 11:00pm, every night.
- Our first meeting was 5:15, 5:30.
That was our first.
- 15 minutes.
(laughing)
- I can't believe
that was the first one, that's--
- Every single, Caleb, that
was diproprionate thing
that was most ridiculous, right?
- [Seth] Mic isn't on sync
right now. (distant talking)
- Yeah, a freak, where
some weird shit happens
where like, that's why like in here
where like, if something happens,
I'm like, uncomfortable in the
not doing for three minutes
out of 18 hours in a day.
- Is it true
you only see two movies
every year or something?
Like one movie?
- Yeah.
In this, like, going to the movie theater,
and watching a movie,
happens only December
during holiday break, and
I'll see one and/or two movies
during that time.
- That's crazy.
- See, I need to watch movies.
- No,
that's great, that's your process.
I need to watch the Jets take
a fucking shit in Cleveland.
(laughing)
Like everybody's got their own like,
yo, like, everybody's got their own thing.
Like, I, I don't judge
people watching movies
or Netflix, or things of that nature.
I think escapism is remarkable.
I think I've hit this crazy
vortex where my fucking work
is my hobby, my process, my love,
that I'm just like, right,
like, I fucking like,
I come home at 3:00 in the
morning from Cleveland.
I've been goin' hard
all day, this is like,
I've got three, four, more
things after this tonight.
So, we're already 8:45,
and I'm wakin' up tomorrow
at 6:00 to go garage saleing,
on a day when I can actually
catch up with some rest.
- People don't understand that
that's--
- And people are like,
and then this is where I get crazy.
So, that's me.
- People feel bad for you.
- And then people--
- Maybe not.
- Look at me are like, then
like, my friends are like,
wake up at 10:13 on Saturday
like, yo, I'm so tired.
(laughing) And I'm like,
I'm gonna break your nose.
(laughing) Like, I just,
you know, but that's okay.
Like, what, you know,
my ambition is absurd.
And so, like, I have to sleep in my bed.
Bro, there's no process,
there's your process.
You need to figure out
you, and if you're the kind
of person that needs 11 hours of sleep
because that's your DNA, then
get your 11 hours of sleep
and dominate the other
13, if you're the kind
that needs an hour for
breakfast, lunch, and dinner,
and watch YouTube videos of like, fuckin',
people climbing trees, and
like, that's how you roll,
then enjoy your three hours of watching
people climb trees during
your food consumptions hours,
and do you, like I hate that
people try to be like me.
I have ridiculous,
over-the-top, natural energy
that makes no sense to
me, and anybody else
that knows anything
about me, that's just me.
And cool, it works for me in some ways.
Here's a way it doesn't
work, when you're that much
of a beast, you're often
the emotional and financial
fucking infrastructure for
everything you touch and see.
So, like, you know, everything's
got pro's and con's.
So like, don't wish on
yourself, just figure out
who the fuck you are and do.
- Yeah.
What would be your number-one
industry to scale for,
for social media marketing,
like as far as who should
we target--
- All of them.
- Right now--
- All of them, okay.
- Dude, selling wine,
selling sneakers, selling
art, like, whatever,
they're all big, every
market's big as fuck.
What do you wanna sell, are you into like,
you wanna be a barber
one day and sell blades?
Like blades fuckin' came
out, blades dominated.
Fuckin' razor blades.
- Yeah.
- Like, fuckin' razor blades
over the last seven years
is what it was, Dollar Shave Club.
- [Mark] If it has
margin, it can be scaled.
- That's exactly right, dude, everything.
People buy everything, fucking bananas,
I'll give you one, bananas.
(laughing)
I want you to become the
banana king of the internet.
I'm being dead fucking serious.
Like, be the banana guy.
(laughing)
- You better like bananas.
- When I was watching
the Jets last night, I
was sitting there like,
aw, Gary Vee hates that, for
getting the touchdown right?
(laughing)
Dude, I was fuckin',
you don't even want, I wanted to,
honestly, I wanted to like, kill people.
- Did you like the celebration?
- Thanks for calling in, brother.
What's that?
- He wiped--
- His ass, Isaiah?
- Yeah, it was--
- It was honestly like,
he played in Cleveland,
he's frustrated, dude,
the whole thing sucks.
Fucking football, fucking Jets.
Question of the day,
you guys get to ask it,
what's your question?
- Question of the day.
I'd say for us, we wanna understand
why consumers are loyal to brands?
- I would say--
- What makes you
loyal to a brand?
- I would say,
what is your favorite brand and why?
- Why.
- That's it.
- Love it.
- 'Cause that's what
we wanna know.
- Thanks for being on, guys.
Congratulations, love being with you guys.
- Thanks for hookin' us up.
- You keep asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.
(uptempo funky music)